derrière cette porte il n'y a pas de
tabous pas de sujets trop délicat une
seule restriction il faut être un garçon
pour entrer dans la classe j'ai nommé
les jeunes autour de la table ont choisi
de faire partie du programme
wise guys gars sont allumés en français
un programme d'éducation sexuelle où
l'on parle autant de consentement de
plaisir sexuel que de la façon dont les
hommes et les femmes sont représentées
dans les médias aujourd'hui la
discussion porte sur les droits humains
il respect est-ce qu'on peut insulter
une fille qui porte une jupe très courte
non croit edgy women le problème ce
n'est pas l'habit mans
mais comment la société le perçoit qu
elle ce genre de commentaires sort de la
bouche d'une adolescente 14 ans réjouit
le responsable du programme
c'est exactement pour ça que son
organisation le centre de santé sexuelle
de calgary a créé wise guys il ya huit
ans on a tous grandi avec cette idée que
les garçons vont toujours se comporter
comme des garçons c'est correct qui soit
sûre bulin qu'il soit agressif parfois
ce sont des gars après tout mais où est
ce qu'on met la limite avec le programme
on veut montrer aux jeunes qu'il y a
plein de façons d'être un homme
et pour que les garçons participent
qu'ils se sentent vraiment à l'aise
d'aborder des sujets tabous il fallait
dit les organisateurs de wise guys créer
un espace juste pour eux sont des filles
open
le fait qu'on soit juste des gants pour
s'exprimer plus librement en juge pas
entre nous on peut montrer nos émotions
mais devant une fille je répare cas se
moque de moi
assez d'accord de tchatche il est
responsable du programme nous on dit
dans le passé souvent quand on parle et
d'éducation sexuelle
on visait d'abord et avant tout les
filles on voulait les protéger on
voulait prévenir des grossesses non
désirées à l'adolescence c'est très bien
dit il mais il faut pas négliger les
garçons
les enseignants sont tous des jeunes
hommes auxquels les élèves peuvent
s'identifier et le ton n'est pas
toujours sérieux des menaces pour la
leçon sur les condoms organise un
concours avec des démonstrateurs en bois
qui ont la forme de pénis
la classe est divisé en deux groupes
l'équipe qui réussit à mettre le plus de
préservatifs sur les démonstrateurs
l'emportent
l'idée s'est normalisée l'usagé du
condom ça vraiment changer la culture de
l'école d'avoir ce programme des
résultats en tout cas sont encourageants
martin poirier a été directeur de la
première école qui a mis en place le
programme il ya huit ans les jeunes de
wise guys ont créé un groupe de soutien
aux élèves lgbt qu ils ont même me faire
de la cyberintimidation quand des photos
compromettantes d'une élève circulait
sur internet
alors on a pu intervenir administration
pour arrêter ça tout de suite tu vois
tout de suite hein et pacsés cette
ouverture ce changement de comportement
ce changement de culture lucky fixer un
programme incroyable les responsables de
wise guys prévoit déjà à étendre le
programme dans d'autres villes cette
année et éventuellement dans d'autres
provinces
et bien sûr il y à des défis
est ce qu'une fois à l'extérieur de la
classe les jeunes de wise guys devons
faire preuve d'autant de maturité et j'y
crois qu'il n'est pas prêt d'oublier ce
qu'il a appris je sais que moi j'ai
changé depuis que je suis dans l'ouest
garde si le programme s'étend ailleurs
le on risque de tous de venir plus tôt